we want to figure out the limit
the limit as x approaches 1
of the expression x
over x minus 1
minus 1 over the natural log of
x
so let's just see what happens when we
just try to plug in the one what happens
if we evaluate this expression at one
well then we're going to get
we're gonna get a one here over one
minus 1 so we're going to get something
like a 1 over 0
minus
over and what's the natural log of 1. e
to the what power is equal to 1. well e
to the or anything to the 0th power is
equal to 1. so e to the 0th power is
going to be equal to 1 so the natural
log of 1 is going to be
0. so we get the strange undefined 1
over 0 to minus 1 over 0. it's this
bizarre looking undefined form but it's
not the indeterminate type of form that
we looked for in l'hopital's rule we're
not getting a zero over a zero we're not
getting an infinity over infinity so you
might just say hey okay this is a
non-l'hopital's rule problem we're gonna
have to figure out this limit some other
way and i would say well you know don't
don't give up just yet maybe we can
manipulate this algebraically somehow so
that it will give us the l'hopital
indeterminate form and then we can just
apply the rule
and to do that let's just see if what
happens if we add these two expressions
so if we add them so this expression
let's if we add it'll be well the common
denominator is going to be x minus 1
x minus 1 times the natural log of x i
just multiplied the denominators and
then the numerator is going to be
is going to be well if i i multiply
essentially this whole term by natural
log of x so it's going to be x natural
log of x x natural log of x
and then this whole term i'm going to
multiply by x minus 1. so minus x minus
one
so minus
x
minus one and you could break it apart
and see that this expression and this
expression is the same thing
this right here
that right there is the same thing as x
over x minus 1 because the natural log
of x's cancel out let me get rid of that
and then
this right here
this right here is the same thing as 1
over natural log of x because the x
minus 1's cancel out so hopefully you
realize all i did is i added these two
expressions so given that let's see what
happens if i take the limit
as x approaches one of this thing
because these are the same thing do we
get anything more interesting
so what do we have here we have one
times the natural log of one the natural
log of one of zero so we have a zero
here so that is a zero
minus one minus zero so that's going to
be another zero minus zero so we get a
numerator and we get a 0 in the
numerator and in the denominator we get
a 1 minus 1 which is 0
times the natural log of 1 which is 0 so
0 times 0 that is 0.
and there you have it we have the
indeterminate form that we need for
l'hopital's rule assuming that if we
take the derivative of that and we put
it over the derivative of that that that
limit exists so let's try to do it
so this is going to be equal to if the
limit exists
this is going to be equal to the limit
as x approaches
1. and let's take the derivative
in magenta i'll take the derivative of
this numerator right over here
and for this first term just do the
product rule derivative of x is 1
and then so 1 times the natural log of x
the derivative of the first term
times the second term and then we're
going to have plus the derivative of the
second term plus 1 over x times the
first term that's just the product rule
so 1 over x times x we're going to see
that's just 1. and then we have
minus
minus the derivative of x minus 1. well
the derivative of x minus 1 is just 1.
so it's just going to be minus 1.
and then all of that is over
all of that is over
the derivative of this thing so let's
take the derivative of that over here
so the derivative of the first term of x
minus 1 is just 1 multiply that times
the second term you get natural log of x
and then plus the derivative of the
second term derivative of natural log of
x is 1 over x
times x minus 1
times
times x minus 1. i think we can simplify
this a little bit this 1 over x times x
that's a 1. we're going to subtract 1
from it so these cancel out right there
and so this whole expression can be
rewritten as the limit
as x approaches 1. the numerator is just
natural log of x
do that in magenta natural log of x and
the denominator is the natural log of x
plus
x minus 1
over
x
so let's try to evaluate this limit here
so if we take x approaches 1 of natural
log of x
that will give us a well natural log of
zero of one is zero
and over here we get natural log of one
which is natural log of one is zero
and then plus one minus one
over plus 1 minus 1
over 1. well that's just going to be
another zero 1 minus 1 is 0. so you have
0 plus 0. so you're going to get a 0
over 0 again
0 over 0. so once again let's apply
l'hopital's rule again let's take the
derivative of that put it over the
derivative of that so this if we're ever
going to get to a limit is going to be
equal to the limit
the limit
as x
approaches 1 of the derivative of the
numerator
1 over x right the derivative of ln of x
is 1 over x
over the derivative of the denominator
and what's that well derivative of
natural log of x is
1 over x plus the derivative of x minus
1 over x right actually you could view
it this way as 1 over x times x minus 1.
well derivative of x to the negative 1
we'll take the derivative of the first
one times the second thing and then the
derivative of the second thing times the
first thing so the derivative of this
first term x to the negative one is
negative x to the negative two times the
second term times x minus one
plus the derivative of the second term
which is just one
times the first term plus one over x so
this is going to be equal to
i just had a random thing pop on my
computer sorry for that little sound if
you heard it but where was i oh let's
just simplify this over here we were
doing our l'hopital's rule so this is
going to be equal to
this is going to be equal to let me
this is going to be equal to if we
evaluated x is equal to 1 the numerator
is just one over one which is just one
so we're definitely not going to have an
indeterminate or at least a zero over
zero form anymore and the denominator is
going to be if you evaluated one it's
this is one over one which is one
plus
negative one to the negative two so
or you say one to the negative two is
just one it's just a negative one but
then you multiply that times one minus
one which is zero so this whole term is
going to cancel out and then you have a
plus another one over one so plus one
and so this is going to be equal to one
half and there you have it using
l'hopital's rule on a couple of steps we
solve something at least initially
didn't look like it was zero over zero
we just added the two terms got zero
over zero took derivatives of the
numerators and denominators two times in
a row to eventually get our limit